Speaker 1: Today, we're going to be speaking
with Andy Norman, who studies how ideologies
can short circuit minds.
He's the author of the recently released book
Mental Immunity Infectious Ideas Mind Parasites
and the Search for a Better Way to Think.
Andy, it's so great to have you on today.
Speaker 5: Thank you, David.
It's a pleasure to be here.
Speaker 1: You know, there's all these analogies
these days to infection and immunity and and
inoculation and vaccination.
And you talk about the concept of a mental
immune system and a cultural immune system.
Can you tell us a little bit about those ideas?
Speaker 5: Yeah, so just as our bodies have
immune systems that protect us from infectious
microbes, our minds have immune systems that
protect us from infectious ideas.
These immune systems aren't talked about a
great deal in the sciences yet, but the sciences
are waking up to the fact that that they exist.
There's now a mountain of evidence that they
do exist and had to exist because the wrong
ideas could get our ancestors killed.
And so we're learning to actually science
is actually learning to view minds as having
filtering systems that are meant to fact,
to screen out bad ideas and let in good ones.
And of course, they can malfunction in all
kinds of ways that lead to social dislocation
and political turmoil, among other things.
Speaker 1: So sometimes people will ask me
what is the best way to protect oneself from
fake news and disinformation, propaganda,
et cetera.
And in my mind, the inoculation that I suggest
is a foundation of critical thinking and understanding
how we evaluate whether something we've been
told is something we should believe and understanding
how media works and and media literacy.
Is that an example of such an immune system?
Speaker 5: Absolutely.
So I think the concept that comes closest
to mental immunity is critical thinking.
And and so if you want to get a good head
start on an understanding of mental immunity,
start with critical thinking for sure.
It turns out, though, that the concept of
critical thinking is a very crude instrument
for helping to build mental immunity.
And and it turns out the critical thinking
skills can be weaponized for an ideology not
just employed to create fair minded thinkers.
Speaker 1: Can you give an example of how
of how that can happen?
Speaker 5: Well, sure.
So I think universities have been cranking
out people who are trained to one or another
degree in critical thinking for decades and
decades.
And often what happens is that I meant that
a college graduate will use their ability
to dissect arguments, to defeat arguments
they dislike, but not to employ them to clarify
or modify their own thinking.
Speaker 1: So is that sort of a confirmation
type bias use of a tool?
Speaker 5: Exactly.
So psychologists call confirmation bias the
tendency to basically let in information that
fits your political or ideological preconceptions,
let those in uncritically, but then respond
critically or cynically to information that
that challenges your point of view.
And the problem with that is that's a recipe
for close mindedness and tribal tribal thinking.
And we absolutely need to get past that if
we hope to actually become wiser versions
of ourselves
Speaker 1: when it comes to specific rhetorical
tactics.
I'd be curious to see what you found about
what is more effective versus what is less
effective.
We've talked on the program about things like
using a Socratic method of questioning to
get one, to reexamine their own beliefs and
come to the conclusion themselves that they
may be mistaken.
This is sort of, in a sense, I think, an idea
from Dale Carnegie from the 30s or whenever
he wrote How to Win Friends and Influence
People.
And the defensibility question, which is what
evidence, if it existed, would get you to
change your mind.
And then using that like as a jumping off
point.
I mean, are these are these tools maybe effective?
Speaker 5: Absolutely.
So in the book, I argue that the famous Socratic
method is basically a way of testing ideas
with questions and seeing if they can withstand
the questioning that that's one of the most
powerful minded documents ever invented.
And in the book, I take that mind innoculate
and refine it into something I called the
new Socratic method, which I argue can be
something like a mind vaccine and take our
critical thinking to a whole new level.
I also love the question, what would change
your mind?
That that is a powerful question for both
strengthening and modulating.
Mental immune systems, so just as the the
body's immune system can get out of kilter
and attacked the body's own tissues or let
in covid right, let in the coronavirus, the
mind's immune system can get it confused and
attack the wrong things.
So a conspiracy theorist is somebody who becomes
hyper cynical about traditional or mainstream
sources of information and their own critical
mindset.
It's almost like an autoimmune disorder.
Speaker 1: I was going to say it's almost
like this cytokine storm we talk about with
the pandemic where the immune system goes
crazy because they're, you know, for whatever
reason, I'm not a doctor, but, you know, this
overactive defense mechanism.
Speaker 5: That's exactly, exactly the right
analogy.
So cytokines are actually antibodies.
They're the things the mind body's immune
system produces to fight off what it perceives
to be a threat.
And sometimes the body's immune system overreacts
to something that's genuinely harmless.
So when you have an allergic reaction to pollen,
that's your body overreacting to something
that really doesn't harm it.
It's the overreaction that makes you miserable.
Right.
And our minds can make the exact same kind
of mistake.
We can attack genuinely reliable information
because it comes from somebody on the other
side of the political divide, say, and in
this way, our minds do more to protect our
chosen identities than they do to actually
help us find the truth.
You actually have to train your minds immune
system to care about truth and to care less
about your ideological identity.
And when you do that, you become wiser.
Speaker 1: Yeah, the conspiracy theory thing
is interesting.
We've interviewed experts on conspiracies
and conspiratorial thinking, and they're you
know what?
How can you distinguish between healthy skepticism
and what's on the other side, which is this
never ending and unsatisfying bull cynicism,
which is often what is at the core of conspiratorial
thinking?
Speaker 5: Yeah, you're exactly right.
I think it's long been a tenet of the critical
think of of critical thinking advocates that
we think critically, we ask the right questions.
But those other guys right there are insufficiently
critical.
But it turns out you can be too critical for
your own good, just as it's possible to be
under critical it's possible to be overcritical.
And so the truly healthy mind is one that
strikes the right balance between suspicion
and trust.
Speaker 1: Yeah, that you know, the a lot
of this, as you sort of alluded to, is my
family is huge mental health family, a lot
of people and psych psychiatrists, psychologists,
etc. and there's this really common psychotherapy
question, which is what would it mean to you
if what you believe isn't true, which is really
about one's identity kind of being tied up
in their beliefs.
And so that's probably to some degree at the
core of why we attach so much to the beliefs
we come in with.
And and those beliefs are resistant to change
that.
Speaker 5: That's right.
And it turns out that we're more attuned to
the usefulness of ideas than we are to their
truth.
So if an idea feels useful to us, a lot of
times will cling to it even after it's been
debunked.
Speaker 1: Right.
Speaker 5: And but to genuinely deepen your
understanding of the world and to become to
grow morally, you actually have to learn to
care as much or more about truth as you do
about the usefulness of the ideas that fill
your health.
Your head, I should say, by the way, that
genuinely wise people don't look only at what
I call upstream evidence for truth and also
care about the downstream causal consequences
of what we believe.
Right.
Both matter.
Speaker 1: The you know, I'm thinking of the
idea that some hold people who are economically
disadvantaged, that it's, you know, immigrants
from Mexico that are responsible for them,
either not having a job or having lost a job
or whatever the case may be.
And that seems to fit that idea that you mention
of there's a convenience to believing that
that there's a usefulness to that, because
maybe it takes attention away from other economic
factors that are truly responsible or from
whatever personal responsibility there may
be behind one's economic circumstances, whatever,
whatever the truth is
Speaker 5: that that's exactly right.
So scapegoat scapegoating immigrants is has
long been a staple of demagogs.
And what it does is it is that it very reliably
hijacks mental immune systems of.
The demagogs supporters, so if you peddle
fear of immigrants, a lot of times the fear
will trigger auto in cognitive auto immune
overreactions right there by duping your own
followers and by hero by your followers.
I mean a demagogs followers.
One's following one's followers.
Right.
So so fear mongers actually are hijacking
the minds of their own followers.
And many of us in America right now are easily
triggered by the propagandists on our side
of the aisle.
I know that I catch myself all the time overreacting
to the fear mongering of the some of the progressive
activists that I tend to trust and respect.
Speaker 1: What about situations where maybe
two people with different views enter to a
conversation in good faith, really wanting
to sort of like hash out what what is the
truth?
And you get to the situation where it's sort
of like my source versus your source.
And we get through these initial steps where
we ask the questions on what are you basing
your view on?
And I tell you what I'm basing my view on.
And you tell me and the source is just sort
of conflict.
And of course, a really deep study might show
us the ways in which statistics may have been
manipulated or whatever, but it sort of starts
to get we end up in the weeds, so to speak.
What is it?
What should be done in that case?
How can we move forward towards truth in situations
like that?
Speaker 5: Yeah.
So to actually work through such disagreements
in conversation requires patience and a kind
of patience that we seem to have forgotten
the virtue of in this in these breakneck times.
But but in principle, every one of us now
can fact check things by pulling a device
out of our pockets and starting to Google
things.
But the thing to understand is that there's
a ton of unreliable information out there
and a lot of it is on very slick websites
or in carefully manipulated statistical analyzes
so as to get you to support one or another
political or religious ideology.
Right.
So so you need to be very skeptical.
You need to look closely at the sources you
tend to rely on, both online and in the mainstream
media and and do your fact checking to find
out which ones are really reliable and ask
yourself who benefits from peddling this kind
of information and and what what incentives
might they have for skewing it in a way that
that might manipulate me?
Speaker 1: Last thing I wanted to ask you
about there, there's sometimes there's talk
of sort of like benign conspiratorial beliefs.
And often the one that's cited is like flat
earth as an example, someone who believes
flat earth, it's OK.
You know, it's kind of wacky, but it really
is not damaging.
But then the counter that I've heard frequently
is someone who believes that likely doesn't
believe only that and flat earth and anti-Semitism
have huge overlap, etc.
How should we evaluate, like which battles
are worth fighting and and sort of adjudicating
some of the because there's just so much that
could be focused on and kind of thinking through
that fantastic question.
Speaker 5: David, so a Canadian research team
just came out last year with a study that
shows that if you indulge in irresponsible
thinking in one domain, you weaken your mother's
immune system in ways that compromised your
ability to distinguish fact from fiction in
other domains.
Right.
So if you indulge in wishful thinking for
the sake of of of harmony with your coreligionists,
you end up becoming more susceptible to conspiracy,
thinking more susceptible to science denial,
more susceptible to propaganda.
So you can't say, oh, I'll just go off and
indulge in wishful thinking in this domain
and expect it not to compromise your mental
function.
So I actually argue in the book that there's
our minds have a linch, our mental immune
systems have a linchpin, and that linchpin
is.
Always yield to the better reason, never let
wishful thinking dissuade you from doing the
right thing, which is to believe as much as
possible on the basis of the best reasons
and evidence available.
So when you begin to move away from evidence
based thinking, you start to compromise your
minds, your mind's immune functioning, and
don't think you can only go a little ways
down this path and.
And not slide further down that path because
the evidence shows that the slope can become
very slippery.
Speaker 1: Yeah, it seems like sometimes going
to a slippery slope is itself fallacious.
But in this case, it seems to really be a
core, a core aspect of how that works.
The book is called Mental Immunity Infectious
Ideas Mind Parasites and the Search for a
Better Way to Think.
We've been speaking with the book's author,
Andy Norman.
Really great having you on.
I so appreciate your time.
Speaker 5: Thank you, David.
It's been a pleasure.